[Applause]
[Music]
this is one of the last new releases of
October and even though it's getting
colder in some parts around the world
our pal Mario is still eagerly awaiting
his chance to parade around without
those trademark overalls but before he
can flex his plumbing pecs we've got
some other big games dropping this week
let's get to it
first off destiny 2 is finally landing
on PC this week I don't know what more I
could say that hasn't already been said
but if you need a refresher here's the
space elevator pitch destiny 2 has new
planets and raids to conquer tons of new
weapons and armor to collect and new
subclasses to experiment with the Ark
Strider subclass lets hunters wield and
electrified staff the warlocks dawn
blade subclass can chuck bolts of
sunlight from midair and the titans new
Sentinel option gives you a special
Captain America style shield to chuck
around the battlefield you can finally
dig in on PC on Tuesday the 24th but if
you feel the need to preview the game
first you can always watch some 4k
gameplay or check out our full review of
the console version speaking of consoles
ps4 is getting a very intriguing new
addition with hidden agenda it's from
the same team behind until dawn but
instead of making choices to get your
teens through a haunted mountain lodge
you're trying to catch a serial killer
and thanks to Sony's Play link app you
don't have to go it alone other players
can join in on their phones and vote on
the choices lead detective Becky Marny
makes but here's the twist
one player gets the titular hidden
agenda and is tasked with sabotaging the
investigation
you can solve murders and find your own
moles when hidden agenda launches on the
24th and cue the bad puns so she was
dead before she hit the ground body down
so priority number one is for us to find
the murder scene
you know what else has a lot of dead
bodies Assassin's Creed but origins is
looking to breathe new life into the
series while taking us back to the
ancient days of Egypt it has the parkour
exploration and battles of the previous
games but this time the combat is much
more deliberate with specific hit boxes
on enemies it's a system you'll
definitely have to learn if you want to
survive the game's new arena battles
we'll see if those features can bring
Assassin's Creed to new heights when
origins come to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
Friday October 27th now let's move from
ancient history to alternate history
what if the Nazis had won World War 2
and taken over the United States that's
the world BJ blaskowitz faces in
Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus
fortunately he has a few new tricks up
his sleeve like mixing and matching
weapons while dual wielding and a big ol
hatchet for brutal melee executions the
second American Revolution begins on ps4
Xbox one and PC on Friday the 27th with
a portable Nintendo's switch version
coming next year
speaking of Nintendo switch it's time
ladies and gentlemen the world-famous
plumbers next big game is Super Mario
Odyssey and no shirt Mario is just one
small part of this adventure taking its
cues from Super Mario 64 in sunshine
Odyssey is all about open-ended
exploration letting you collect moons
coins and all sorts of special costumes
and hats in whatever order you like
you'll have a bunch of giant kingdoms to
explore when Super Mario Odyssey comes
to Nintendo's switch on the 27th fingers
crossed for some special Wario and
Waluigi outfits and those are some of
the hottest games we'll be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with more
new releases next Sunday